and then maybe let's talk a little bit
about kind of the feds response to where
we are now so we've seen that we're in
this deflationary environment dollar
strengthened and asset prices selling
off
you saw the emergency rate cuts to zero
and then you get I have no clue what
number we end up on the quantitative
easing side but it's going to be in the
trillions and it's gonna be big right
and so it may be two trillion or it
could be ten trillion who knows yeah
kind of what do you think about the
response so far and then the shock you
ask people is like do they have another
option it almost feels like they're
doing exactly what they have to do to
keep this going even if we all think
that it's crazy that it's happening it's
almost like they have to do it right
yeah I mean there's two parts to this
one what are they supposed to do and
then what do they have to do so there's
a lot of people who come out and say the
feds should do nothing they should let
the markets run themselves yes that is
what they should do you know free market
and I would love it if that world
existed that world does not exist
central bankers were created with the
express purpose of what is going on
exactly right now they were created so
that when we get into this environment
they can plug the hole with newly
printed money so to think that they're
not going to do it is foolish of course
they're going to do it it's just a
matter of what are the Fed what are the
knock-on effects of them doing it how
successful are they are they successful
the first time or do they have to take
multiple programs to finally get it
under control I'm convinced that they
will eventually get it under control and
the dollar will go much lower I'm also
convinced they're gonna fail before they
get before they're successful so that
kind of that's kind of a long way of
answering your question what do I think
about it now I think they're doing what
they have to do in a crisis you know
when the patient is hemorrhaging you
just want to stop the bleeding right and
then you can figure out the treatment
and that's what central bankers they're
just trying to stop the bleeding right
now they're extending swap lines they're
buying corporate bonds they're doing QE
they're cutting rates to zero
again all the countries are doing this
this isn't just the Fed they're all
doing it they're just trying to
stabilize the system and then they're
gonna have and I think what'll happen
think they will do something it'll
arrest the rise of the dollar maybe the
dollar will even fall for four or five
six months but the issue is that you
have to understand is to your point that
they're doing what they have to do in
the system that they have designed you
either print money to put more
collateral in the system off of which it
can be loaned into existence or you do
the or you just make the loans bigger
right one of those that's the way money
is created it's either physically
printed or it's loaned into existence
those are the two ways we've reached the
point where there's no more loans being
created so they're having to come in and
plug that hole
I think the hole is dramatically bigger
than anybody can conceptualize so the
fact that they're coming in and printing
I don't even know what they've done so
far it's like you know they're doing 125
billion dollars a day in repo they
promised a trillion dollars of this you
know up to two trillion dollars of that
the Congress is going to authorize two
or three trillion dollar fiscal spending
and what's the dollar done it's at its
high of three years it's barely even
backed off right and that just shows me
that the demand is so high can you
imagine a year ago if we just said
they're gonna do all this the dollar
would have fallen to 80 because nobody
believed we could get into this kind of
a dollar scramble but you know what
we're here and now that the the fuse has
been lit I think this thing's gonna
accelerate higher now it doesn't mean
there's not going to be periods of time
where they get it under control before
another fire pops up or another bomb
goes off but the battle now the battle
has started you know the battle was
simmering for a long time but now the
battles on there's gonna be times where
one side wins and the other side wins
but I think before it's all said and
done that this dollar squeeze is going
to squeeze the dollar higher yeah one of
the questions I get so there's a lot of
people listening who will agree with
everything you just said and then
they'll say great I'm an individual how
do I play it right what are my options
not so much as like what's the advise it
to go do but just what are the options
and they'll say should I just hold
dollars in my bank account should I go
and find currency pairs and short you
know something against the dollar like
what are you kind of tell folks is just
the options on the table if they could
look at if their interest is yours well
short answer is there's a few different
things you can do the correct answer it
kind of depends on where you live and
what your home currency is you know and
as a general rule I would say it's kind
of the same answer for everybody but
it's also a little different I think the
best place to be over the next two or
three years is United States assets now
it doesn't mean there's not going to be
paying along the way but I think if I am
sitting in Sydney Australia and I see
what's happening to the Australian
dollar I know what the the Royal Bank of
Australia has said they're going to do
to the Australian dollar and I know the
growth prospects for Australia pale in
comparison to to those for United States
I would rather buy coca-cola let the
Aussie dollar go down six or seven
percent collect the four percent
dividend from coca-cola there I've got a
ten percent return and if coca-cola
happens to go up two or three percent
that's all the better right and even if
it goes down ten percent I'm still even
so so you know I think the first thing
you should do is if you're is whole
dollars you know most people in the
United States we just hold dollars
because it's our natural currency but I
think if you're overseas and especially
if you have a business that has
liabilities in dollars you should
definitely hold dollars versus your
local currency that's the first thing if
you then have some excess savings which
you can deploy into US dollar assets
maybe you buy some big you know the Dow
or maybe even some short-term Treasuries
I think that would be a good idea I
think you should buy some gold I think
you should have some Bitcoin if you
could again there's kind of a
progression right if you if you have
enough liquidity to do all this stuff
maybe you do all of it but I think the
first thing you do is you know your own
just you you have your cash or your
savings and US dollars you know where do
we set up a fund specifically to play
this now this fund is it's only geared
towards high net worth individuals you
know again I would prefer it wasn't only
for high net worth individuals but this
is these are the regulatory requirements
that have been put down on us so it is
somewhat limited to certain individuals
but to anybody that would want to talk
about that in more detail I'm happy to
talk to them about the opportunities we
see we see incredible opportunities
we're having a lot of success and we
think we'll continue to have a lot of
success in that strategy but I think in
general I think we're still in deflation
I think we're probably going to have
deflation for a little while on a global
basis I think we're going to continue to
have deflation but in the
not-too-distant future I think we're
going to start to see some inflationary
effects in the United States so you know
I can't really give advice over the
internet on what people should do
individually but if you kind of think
about those if you kind of think about
those dynamics maybe it gives you an
idea of how to position yourself